Your 40s are when you stop auditioning
for a life you don't even want. That
exhausting performance where you try to
meet everyone else's expectations while
ignoring your own. It's time to drop the
act. Here's what nobody tells you about
turning 40. You finally have enough life
experience to recognize what doesn't
work. The endless pursuit of external
validation becomes obviously feudal when
you realize the people whose approval
you're seeking aren't even living lives
you admire. Picture this. You're invited
to another networking event that makes
your soul die a little inside. Your
30-year-old self would have gone
convinced it was important for your
career. Your 40-year-old self knows
better. Thanks, but I'm focusing my
energy elsewhere. Becomes your new
superpower. But here's the game changer.
Your 40s hits you with mathematical
reality. If you live to 80, you have
roughly 2,000 weekends left. Suddenly,
that toxic friend who drains your energy
doesn't seem worth 1 12,000th of your
remaining time. This isn't about
becoming selfish. It's about becoming
authentic. Your 40s aren't a midlife
crisis. They're midlife clarity.